recording so you were the first  person at mountain view to receive the  vaccine how do you feel  so far so good they're supposed to be 15  minutes of monitoring but i don't have  any symptoms yet it was i didn't even  feel the shot it was such a tiny little  needle  what did you think after caring for  patients for nine months  oh definitely ready to turn the page i  think this is going to be the key for us  to you know get rid of masks hopefully  and quarantine and lock down so  you know if living in vegas obviously we  need this more than more than any  economy in the u.s we need to reopen and  stay and open at 25 doesn't work for  vegas so this is the way out so yeah